bonjour bonjour pour cette leçon
spéciale italienne aujourd'hui jean
baptiste bonjour stéphane et oui la
partie italienne ont encore une partie
avec quatre ou cinq
avec ce fou qui va aller en c4 on va
voir tout un tas de petites
réjouissances sur le pion sur le pion à
vii une ouverture très riche très
agressive
alors peut-être historiquement et
pourquoi italienne et je pense que ça a
été développé par les italiens à la cour
italienne pendant le pendant la
renaissance voilà c'est ça que nous
avons donc les fameux italien après les
expériences existent et rien qu on peut
aussi dominé le jeu avant que ça passe à
la france est notre fameux philidor
grands joueurs évidemment égal à
l'époque ça donc c'est une ouverture qui
a été très très jouée par les italiens
donc d'où son nom partie italienne tout
simplement donc aussi une ouverture
qu'on va conseiller d'étudier absolument
pour les débutants c'est fondamental oui
alors c'est intéressant quand on est
blanc c'est quand même assez riche
tactiquement il ya beaucoup de beaucoup
d'idées qui peu dynamique et c'est
surtout obligatoire quand on a les noirs
parce que quand on joue et 4,5 et qu'on
joue une italienne
il faut connaître un petit peu de un peu
le truc quand même parce que sinon ça
peut aller très vite va être très vite
ma tout perdre une pièce alors massacre
très rapide ouais on peut passer par la
fenêtre très vite voilà donc c'est à
connaître si avec les banques ont gagné
parties rapides
évidemment il faut tenter l'italien de
toute façon c'est une ouverture à
connaître les débutants joue souvent ça
naturellement déjà même sans connaître
trop de théorie c'est un peu naturel que
le développement sur un développement
naturel autant que vous b5 l'espagnol
pussycat c'est la plus grande diagonale
actifs pour le fou qu'on les rende avoir
loupé on va voir un peu cette ouverture
alors que quatre ou cinq cavaliers trois
classiques ans le cavalier vient
évidemment centre attaque le pion aux
simples oncologiques câble et c6 je
défende janssen est là le coup qui
caractérise d'étals nc caractérise ses
souks ou voilà où ces quatre avec donc
la petite pression sur le plan f cette
parution f 16 à la pure f7 le pion qui
est le moins bien défendus de toute la
position noir puisque il est défendu
qu'une fois et c'est par le roi donc
c'est pas c'est pas le mieux
voilà donc les les blancs d'oeufs
développe naturellement leur pièce sur
cette diagonale qui est la diagonale la
plus active
alors déjà c'est un carrefour pour le
moment en cours et en gros deux groupes
connaître voilà bon il ya des coups
après je dirais des petits coups des
coups un peu un peu passif en plus de
courir un peu passif peut-être en vous
permettre de laisser passer l'orage
avant tout comme un fou et 7 par exemple
et un coup qu'on peut jouer qui est
peut-être un peu plus économique au
niveau de la théorie mais en tout cas
qui n'est pas très réjouissant puisque
après le pion et que tu vas les andes et
si c'est bien il va quoi c'est le fou
donc c'est pas terrible
voilà c'est jouable mais c'est pas le
mieux voilà nous on va plutôt
s'intéresser aujourd'hui stéphane sur
sur deux grandes variantes alors la
première ses cavaliers pts 6 voilà
cavaliers f6 contre attaque directe sur
le pur 4 et l'autre qu'on va voir tout
de suite avant de développer c'est le
kung fu ces cinq toiles a donc cédé 2
gros con qu'on va étudier qui
caractérise les grands ni de la partie
italienne après on rentre dans des
variantes compte utiliser plutôt passive
est relativement facile à maîtriser en
fait il a tout de suite les deux coups
actifs
alors on va peut-être commencer par
carrier sont allés au hasard cavaliers
epsilon qu'on appelle ça la défense des
deux galas et voilà alors là sur cabaye
m6 il ya deux coups pour les blancs
alors
bon il ya un coût même plusieurs mais
bon il ya
un coût qu'il est hantise des joueurs
qui débutent le coup cavaliers g5 le
gros coup c'est un rallye g5 alors
pourquoi tout de suite on rajoute une
pression sur les recettes et la menace
qui semble imparable comme ça à première
vue c'est faire [ __ ] avec 7 voire
cavaliers prend fcn avait quand même la
grosse fourchette entre la tour et la
dame la fameuse fourchette que les
débutants 1
voilà donc c'est pour ça qu'on vous dit
qu'il vaut mieux bien connaître avec les
noirs puisque creton vous joue cavalier
g5 et bien ça craint il faut quand même
être prêt à répondre sont des problèmes
qui ne sont pas insolubles on a pas mal
de solutions alors on n'a pas parlé
aujourd'hui on ne va pas parler je pense
de l'avant tracks faire le fou furieux
avec fous ces cinq cantons connaissent
hao plus travaillés d'entre vous mais
non on va s'intéresser à l'autre aux
plus curieux on va quand même
comme on fait d'habitude vous donner
suffisamment d'armes pour joint une
ouverture correct et est jouable et pas
rentrer dans les variantes beaucoup trop
compliqué alors on a quand même une
façon assez classique de défense de
france est en effet stephen c'est le
coût des 5 voilà voilà le coup des cinq
classiques tout simplement on intercepte
heureusement que lorsqu on intercepte la
pression sur les recettes grâce à
dessein à noter que ceux qui ont des
sites protégés par le cabinet sis et par
là même des 8
jusque-là tout paraît normal puisque le
pur et protéger deux fois ont attaqué
deux fois alors les blancs vont prendre
en d5 voilà mais là on se dit avec les
noirs bien on va reprendre des scènes
alors bon évidemment c'est pas ce qu'on
va faire ça serait quand même trois si
bien sûr voilà pourquoi en fait alors
pourquoi on fait pas qu'un ancien local
et prend des 5
bien heureusement riante ici alors j'ai
une grosse va donc il faut connaître et
puis un coût qui est meilleur encore
mais la grosse variante c'est qu'elle a
des problèmes cette cavale et provincial
37 avec fourchette on se dit donc on est
obligé de prendre avec la roue très
spectaculaire parce qu'on fait une force
est immédiate c'est qu'elle n'est pas
protégé il faut prendre on prend le
cavalier donc on a sacrifié un cavalier
mais mais mais ça va très vite après
quoi la battant on a une attaque double
avec dame f3 qui attaquent le roi qui
attaquent le cavalier le roi et le
cavalier donc si les noirs ne joue pas
le cours eux si c'était le seul vrai et
bien en fait tout simplement si je vous
parce qu'on l'a on va récupérer la pièce
avec un tournage est même pire six jours
g8 par exemple et jouera j'ai vite il se
fait mater voilà donc hors l'entrée
quand même un surmoi g8 on peut même
prendre de la dame vous énorme
on l'apprend cavaliers et après il
apprend dame est ce que c'est c'est ma
tante du coup la foux aussi seul coup et
vous réussissez matt donc la c1 attendit
coup elle avec une petite déception
quand même pour les joueurs qui n'ont
pas qu'ils n'ont pas bien répondu donc
il faudra aussi c'est avec vous je ne
réussisse alors on voit tout de suite
l'idée pour les blancs ils ont sacrifié
évidemment une pièce déjà en échange
d'un pion ou déjà mais surtout un gros
roi au centre quand même une situation
qui est un peu difficile pour les noirs
puisque le roi est amené au centre une
block le fou c'est 8
il aiderait un clouage abominable du fou
du fossé cadre accueille donc avec un
dessin qui ne peut plus bouger et on
sait justement grâce à ce clouage qu'on
va pouvoir trouver les coûts théorique
suivante c'est très facile
voilà on fait cavaler ce match facile
pour le moment auquel ces trois élus
comme le coup très très logique là on me
lance carrément de prendre le cas ici
s'il ya qu un seul il ya deux seul coup
en fait qui protège
ok les 5 ha soit le coût cavaliers aux 7
soit le coût kabylie bkt meilleur lequel
avait quatre c'est le plus agressif et
là il faut faire un art oui petit rock
ou même à 3 on se laisse faire la
fourchette pour que le cavalier soit
déviée on va récupérer dès 5 ans 8
alors on va montrer à trois tout
simplement là on va simplement montrer
l'idée c'est une passe évidemment une
variante que vous aimez on peut montrer
une partie assez fois dans mes
à 3 et la cavalle français de l'échec de
rodez 1 juan et on laisse prendre la
tour mais mais mais et après on prend
que lecavalier avec le karyu la
variation lecavalier avec la menace de
découverte du cavalier évidemment
puisque le fou va faire échec
voilà et puis on a un cavalier a un qui
est pas très frais non plus qu'on va
pouvoir récupérer plus tard peut-être si
le coeur vous en dit on va faire avec t4
four b2 par exemple on va fermer quatre
sous les 2 par exemple on peut amener
très vite aussi la tour sur la case un
malade en ce moment parce que pour
l'instant mais voir une tour en plus
pour se met en place sur blessure
donc c'est pas une variante content
comme ça légèrement ses forces et marne
violence qu'il faut être d'humeur assez
belliqueuse quant aux récents soit autre
chose mais c'est une variante est très
intéressante
alors évidemment on peut aussi jouer
tout simplement petit robe d'esprit avec
l'aluminier avait tout simplement une
grosse attaque voilà on en dire que déjà
là il ya car si ce n'est système que
celle à ce tournoi de jouer ces six
quand même qu'ils écoutent bien sûr il
faudrait que le roi en oc s'est très
vite il va y avoir des coups comme des
quatre organes pour adversaire avec le
roi aussi se sait que ça c'est quelque
chose qui te plaisent aux policiers de
plus on va pas conseillé avec les noirs
si on est débutant de chaussée par une
claque et noir saf ont tous joué sept
banques là avec morpho étrange joueurs
confirmés qui n'a pas peur mais juillet
une attaque qui peut durer 15 20 25 ou
tenir et gagner une finale avec des fois
un peu plus
oui c'est impossible quand on commence
quand on commence à apprendre les
ouvertures et le jeu en général on peut
quand même préciser que au lieu de
cavaliers prend f700 qu'allié prend des
5 alors 5e coup voilà au lieu de carli
preuve cette voie ici voilà voilà le
meilleur coup ici cd4 le meilleur des
cas on va l'imposer par bobby fischer
voilà mais c'est un coût qui est
vraiment
très naturelle puisqu'il ouvre les
lignes y défend le cavalier g5 est
attaqué par adam des huit excavatrices 5
est attaqué on peut toujours proposer
maintenant aucun problème mais on a
gagné commence à devenir une menace
c'est bien de notre notre but surtout
c'est de faire petit rock maintenant
pour attaquer sur la colonne ne qu'on
est en train d'ouvrir
voilà et on veut aussi ouvrir la colonne
des parce que lecavalier d5 est pas
frais en dessin qui dépensent déjà fait
par l'adam donc d4
je dirais que c'est c'est le meilleur
coût c'est devant cavaliers prend f7
même si pour quelqu'un qui à prendre
date avec les noirs les deux coups sont
très embêtant de toute façon a survécu
mais si vous avez des blancs regardez
plutôt délicate que kelly projet cette
fois montré une grande très simple ces
cavaliers six cavaliers prendre les
quatre ici le simple coût c3 et c3
il faudrait bien que les deux cavaliers
là son entretien avec le pouce et 4
voilà ça va être très difficile à
défendre
voilà tout ça fait voilà donc déjà on
peut dire qu'après des quatre c'est un
ami des îles car il s'était toujours
faire si les noirs jouent h6 ici et là
on a gagné deux temps sur la variante là
c'est énorme on ne regarde on a déjà
joué deux t4 qui est un coup très
important dans cette variante ce que
quand le roi et en russie ce sont vos
vrais l'accolade de la d4 et déjà joui
d'un quadrillage mais on va jouer pour
eux un très vite et ça va être horrible
donc c'est très bon à jouer si on a les
blancs qu'on aime la tacc faut pas
hésiter à rentrer dans cette vente avait
été quatre voilà un cavalier de ces
lettres même s'ils ont alors le ce n'est
plus chou le hic quand même c'est qu'on
est pas obligé de reprendre en d5 avec
en décembre alors on va mais on va
revenir maintenant on va retomber dans
cette variante très très connu
alors alors poussé quelques cavaliers m6
cavaliers g5 arrêté cinq donc ici on
avait déjà la ligue 2 on avait déjà
ligne alors des 5
et puis on prend on prend hélas le coup
qu'à masquer la saq mais aulas on l'a
déjà fait on a une belle partie de
kasparov un peu plus haut on va essayer
de retrouver dans le méandre dans les
méandres de nos deux variantes voilà ici
voilà on peut prendre les 5 voilà
cavaliers à cinq ans qu'on joue le coup
qu'à rallier à 5 donc en fait on ne
reprend pas ici reprend pas en dessin
qu'on joue le coup cavalia 5 qui attaque
bah oui on veut d'abord enlever se
foutent de la diagonale hm2f 7 pour
pouvoir ensuite reprendre quand des 5
mais les blancs ils ont un petit groupe
qui va leur permettre de regagner le
tempo perdu à cause du cavalier à 5
c'est fou mais sa quête et donc il faut
parer les chèques et donc du coup alors
là bon on a plusieurs coups mais là les
noirs vont choisir dans la plupart des
partis que l'on peut dresser devant
nantes vont choisir le développement
rapide au lieu des coups un petit peu on
est un peu restreint sur les deux n
arrangent et on va gagner le temps dont
cinq en 2005
c'est un gambit jambes donc ça c'est
important donc ça veut dire que pour les
noirs quand vous êtes affronter soit la
variante la plus agressive la plus la
plus solide la plus la plus tendue voilà
celle qui va vous donner le plus de
de facilité de jeu oui on se retrouve en
défense on se retrouve actif en défense
d'ouverture qui est assez facile à jouer
avec les noirs parce que les coûts sont
toujours les mêmes et puis en gal hors
du temps alors celle ci soit zarzis donc
là on va des blancs sont venus pour ça
ils vont donc garder leurs primes plus
puisque avec leurs pions dessins qu'ils
en prennent un autre tel françois cissé
processes b processes toujours pour
gagner le temps sur le fou qui n'a pas
de bonnes cases maintenant s'attaquer à
noter que le car il ya cinq protège
évidemment le tuant cécile ça c'est très
important
alors la fois aux deux écoule plus
usuels le plus le plus logique parce
qu'il y aura d'autres car tout
simplement me fourvoie le four à 4 il
serait triste pamiers placé en retrait
trop auplata fois ci c'est en fait tout
un peu la tête parce qu'il y aurait fort
pourrait plus faire le rock lacazette
est contrôlé par le finir du mal à
falleron qu'il faudrait jouer des trois
qui ait pas un contre et très
appétissant voilà donc à leurs
ressources des tendances à chis on
repousse les pièces en gagnant du temps
et puis le coach si c'est souvent ici on
va voir pour tout le quart ya pas
beaucoup de bonnes cases
oui donc ils obligés d'aller h3 fiche à
deux ou trois fois mais bon
effectivement on a les mêmes références
sont décidément la serre et donc
carrière 3 et ils jouent leur chien il
mais en fait cela tout simplement à vous
prend ouais on reprend dû plonger avec
d'options iso bien voilà c'est bon c'est
compliqué mais c'est pas très facile à
jouer comme si nos cavaliers froid a
attaqué dans le sas et la grande
barrière qu'il faut qu'il faut connaître
qu'il a plus la plus normale on va dire
que quatre il ya ici on attaque le cas
des f3 qui a pas encore une fois
beaucoup de cases sa disposition ils
font venir en 5 et alors là on peut
jouer food & cie sudam c7 c'est pareil
cette attaque
le cavalier le car il ya pas de case
alors il peut aller en c4 mais ça serait
quand même pas terrible ce qu on
échangerait le
le cavaly sa 5e balle placée mal placé
et puis on refuserait le fou après ça va
être encore le temps au noir de jouer et
on a du mal à bouger après vente les
oreillers nord pourra jouer roger 4
enfin bon c'est ouais c'est donc il faut
jouer des cadres des quatre protège le
cavalier néerlandais un joli coup un qui
est qu'on voit pas souvent en échec mais
que quand même le coup il faut connaître
c'est la prise en passant chez j'avais
comme on l'a fait c'est donc la prison
va appeler la règle car on en profite
le pion à bouger de deux cases on a le
droit le coup d'après uniquement le coup
d'après si un pion et place est
évidemment comme ici sur la quatrième
rangée qu elle est uniquement dans ce
cas là on a droit de prendre des trois
comme si le pion n'avait bougé que d'une
case on ne va pas faire ce coup que le
coup d'après ou un pion à bouger de deux
cases donc le coup d'après du premier
coup d'un pion qui a bougé de 2,4 c'est
le seul cas on ne peut pas jouer si le
pion était en d3 au départ il y avait
joué les quatre on peut pas faire la
prise en passant il faut que je la
rejette deux cases c'est pour rattraper
parce que la règle des en fait de
l'avancée des deux pions qu'on le dit
souvent dans ses leçons a été inventée
plus tard elle donc c'est pour pallier
le fait qu'avant pour verser des règles
un petit peu désuète recommencer ce soir
de prise aux passants qui sentent
vraiment d'en faire des erreurs a ajouté
après c'est vrai mais c'est des règles
un petit peu bizarre quand même un peu
bizarre bizarre là mais ça donne du
charme aussi au jeu et à noter quand
même en anglais on dit en passant aux
patineurs français qui est qui prime
mais le français est encore bien de
passer dans tous les règlements fidh est
exactement mais c'est la fédération
internationale télé en france en france
à paris exactement
en 1924 en 1921 alors puis on prend des
trois cavaliers prendrait trois donc là
on reprend in extremis du cavalier on
récupère le fou en aura le cavalier la
prise de la dame donc c'est une très
jolie passe d'armes qu'il faut qu'il
faut maîtriser un faux bien réfléchir en
dessous des 6 et là on sait la
constatation bien que les blancs ont
gagné un pion donc ils ont toujours
leurs avantages matériels
en revanche ils sont très en retard au
niveau du développement
mais la théorie moderne pense quand même
que les blancs peuvent jouer ça parce
que la guerre quand même un pion le pyro
est important la structure est bonne et
c'est vrai qu'on a la perception
évidemment il ya le pion ces six
sociétés isolé pour les 3 à 5 et un peu
hors jeu donc on a quand même des
arguments pour pouvoir cette variante
alors on va montrer encore quelques
coups je pense que c'est un pétrole
alors b3 très vite il faut faire
mettront assez vite alors b3 un double
intérêt
oui on va pouvoir sortir le fond de baie
de cannes très belle et ronald notamment
le cabanial 6 et surtout aux limites
lecavalier à 5 voilà qu'à laisser un peu
plus ses 80 kg à cette rave a dit
j'étais mal placé on vous parlait tout à
l'heure et bien ne peut pas se recycler
sur la caste secal vers le centre il
fallait qu en baisse est ce qui me
paraît jouissance qui est pas
réjouissant donc on va jouer plus tard
dans la plupart des partis on verra le
mas neuf c5 et c6 donc mais trois le
coup logique pour les noirs ces petites
erreurs parce que s'il est blanc assis
noir par contre prénom age 2 on peut
envisager dans ce cas la veine et blanc
après fondé deux après four b2 la vallée
ces trois dames d2 par exemple faire un
grand roque pourquoi moyens et la
colonne h est ouverte et surtout et
surtout les noirs ne pourront pas faire
petit rock parce que la donne à tout
rachat sera très actif sur le pion à
chis et dès que le fou h2 va partir eh
bien on pourrait imaginer fou prend
cavaliers f6 est plongée des structures
et ont des structures elles rentrent
noir parce qu'ils seront obligés de
prendre un rêve cissé lazio pourrait
reprendre en chiffon c'est un petit peu
abstrait en tout cas four b2 avec cette
idée que si les noirs veut le faire
petit rock qui vont avoir un problème
parce que les pièces blanches sont très
bien placés et puis c'est pas dans
l'esprit du groupe
mon compteur peut récupérer un besoin il
faut toujours regarder mais là les
blancs eux rejoue dans l'esprit du
granby vols viendront de l'option pour
retrouver d'activité donc ici petit rock
food et deux soupers ne comprends
toujours pas bien naturel 2e tour est
vite donc maintenant attention puisque
le fou eux deux et en étant attaqué on
peut avoir des menaces de type fou g4
avec un affaiblissement dramatique
côté bilan exact et puis on a ce coup
donc avec une double utilité
ce courage 3 pour les blancs donc il
faut jouer à trois points bréchet est
fou proche d'eux et fruges et 4 comme tu
le disais voilà et en même temps il ya
plus de fourrage de l'effectif est donc
là maintenant les noirs peuvent jouer
par exemple kb24 coopté bel et bien
centré euros mais placé au centre et
puis on évite évidemment un fonds prend
h6 et la petit rock mais un petit rigolo
c'est bon c'est une longue suite théorie
c'est quand même l'un donc là c'est
quand même beaucoup voilà mais c'est des
coups qui font connaître absolument dans
ce genre de cette jackson minimum du
bagage théorique qu'il faut avoir dans
cette partie italienne vous allez que
c'est quand même assez lourds
bon c'est des coups qui soit simple à
comprendre parce que c'est à chaque fois
c'est une menace en main on parle de
menace à ce que faisait presque forcé
mais c est quand même assez long mais
fondamentale est fondamentale et surtout
même quand on quand on débute ou qu'on
est encore disons un joueur cas pas
encore atteint le niveau international
il faut absolument maîtriser cette
ouverture puisque on va en risque de la
retrouver très souvent parce que la
défense et de la partie italienne est
une partie très souvent joué
des cantons début tout échec voilà donc
ça c'était la variante avec un léger 5
c'était la variante avec avec un léger 5
alors on va revenir sur tf6 même pris 46
on va passer peut-être un peu de tout
sur l'autre avec détroit qu'une variante
alors voilà galbraith possible c'est
avec détroit qui comme ça voilà donc un
jeu un peu plus lent on va pas se lancer
à l'attaqué tout de suite avec cavaliers
kerry joseph 5
voilà c'est la variante kindu tranquille
piano piano alors à noter on va vous
donner une idée c'est qu'après fouet
cette petit rock au high rock donc ça
c'est normal
tommelein joue par exemple tour eu un
qui est logique on protège enfin et
surtout un oui on se protège depuis le 4
mai on envisage sur des cinq évidemment
d'avoir une tour qui attaquent le pion à
500 me à empêcher des 5 voilà exacte et
après le coup des six alors on a ce
qu'on appelle notre monde beaucoup de
termes italien dans cette partie italien
c'est le joko piano john holland voilà
djoko pianissimo cc3 est tous avec la
même idée que dans la partie espagnole
on va la jouer plus tard des 4 une fois
qu'on aura empêché évidemment voilà un
fou g4 qui attaquera le cavaly c3 et on
peut d'ailleurs dans cette partie très
vite se retourner l'impulsion de type
espagnol
alors oui c'est même déjà en route ça
ressemble quand même fortement une
partie spagnol ça ressemble donc voilà
exactement
donc ces trois
les des cavaliers des deux cavaliers f1
combien la partie espagnole pendant la
partie espagnole
je veux qu'il y en ait deux cavaliers
feront va envisager des a4 sur sur des
possibilités à 6 des cinq mois ce que
les noirs peuvent jouer le coup cavalia
dans ce cas là on va sans doute jouer
faux b5 et on pourra ramener le pion par
a4 et par ses deux ans l'alliance qui
permettra de regagner le temps perdu ou
on avale un fou ces quatre baies 5 l'on
pourra jouer poucet de cette petite
précision
avant ces trois ans le coût des six on
peut peut-être remettre la position
voilà et après le petit rock et le coude
et si c'est bien et noir aucune menace
donc il ne faut pas oublier ils menacent
positionnelle qui est de jouer cavalier
à 5 qui est de prendre le fou qu'avec
1,5 alors maintenant oui bien sûr cercle
assez large ou par genre h3
allez on y va la vanille à 5 comme il ya
cinq est le fou même si van bay 5 qui
sera pris puisque mes cinq à six voies
l'argent fou à 4 b saint malo qui sera
pas perdu il sera échangé contre le
cavalier ce qui n'est pas une bonne
affaire
ce qu'il préfère c'est un superbe fou
puisque il tape ici sur la glace et un
statut de plus important de cavaliers
parce que l'on sait pas encore dans
cette position si les pions vont passer
c'est changer s'ils ne s'en va pas être
complètement ouvert donc on respecte
encore un peu le statut du fou et puis
c'est le foot italien une faillite ap /
fc danse et le vin c'est le foot à l'e3
sur ces blancs efficacement chez le foot
est un faux pas ne faut pas louper
alors voilà donc on va regarder
maintenant alors toujours dans cette
partie si calme c'est ça qui était un
autre volet italienne on va regarder
deuxième volet de la de la leçon sur
l'italienne c'est avec tous ces 5
on va regarder pousser 5 qui est là par
contre la vraie partie italienne envers
là on a vu la défense et de cavaliers là
c'est pas une défense c'est carrément
une sorte de contre attaques dynamiques
ou de développement dynamique
ouais alors on en joue
ou adhèrent ce de façon symétrique donc
nous mêmes alors avec les doigts on tape
si on a un jeu qui est un peu lent avec
les blancs on les fait clair les noirs
vont égaliser la partie puisqu'ils ont
développé leur plaisent à peu près de la
même manière ils ont la même activité de
pièces alors la théorie donc va se baser
sur cette sortie du fou pour essayer de
trouver le meilleur coup alors quand est
ce qu'on va faire pour exploiter ce fou
qui ans est simple il faut essayer de
l'attaqué facile d'attaquer alors temps
particulièrement en essayant de jouer un
des quatre rapidement mais il ya un
autre
notre idée qui est très intéressante
alors laquelle tu est remise au goût du
jour par garry kasparov himself et que
fisher a joué aussi que fisher a joué
que beaucoup de grands joueurs ont joué
qui est le grand mythe evans alors on va
montrer ce qu'en dit puisque c'est
l'essence même de la partie italienne
ceux qui habitent là tout cela ne les
aurai du capitaine capitaine evans donc
c'est une idée regardez c'est très très
beau b4 voile alors ça c'est très joli
puisqu'en fait on va dévier une des deux
pièces en or et en générant le prendre
du fou un oui parce que du cavadee en
fait on poserait tout de suite la
défense du pur 2,5 et donc on aurait un
fort taux de produits centre on va voir
l'idée c'est qu'après je vous prends des
quatre quais quasiment forcé donc c'est
une jambe et on a donné un pion ne faut
pas hésiter dans la partie terrain de
nîmes pions pour gagner du dynamisme de
la rapidité même kasparov a joué ça donc
c'est jouable ainsi même s'ils cassent
pas la jouer c'est bien que il estimé
qu'il avait au moins de l'âge de votre
beaucoup de foursquare est même en train
je crois qu'il a battu à londres avec ça
là bas tu attends attends maintenant
quelques manques en vain - qui choque
pas du monde est encore plus lourd et
fait danser quand même énorme
d'ailleurs anne en deux
maintenant j'ai vu qu'on avait joué
récemment un gros beats evans
j'ai vu lever la tête pendant trois
minutes dans une partie rapide au web
apps huit mois c'est de se rappeler de
ces analyses
ouais de 95 ans m'a dit mon dieu il a
rebaissé la tête il a tout joué à thème
ou jusqu'au gain de son équipe de
préparateurs avait préparé gambeat evans
ça veut dire qu'ils n'ont pas pris l art
est à la légère kasparov lui même avait
prévu ça dans son bagage
alors en fait on a tiré le fou en b 4
pour pouvoir gagner le tempo en c3 alors
on l'a tous ses droits
rad avait l'idée donc c'est toujours
n'est mis des siècles à on a gagné on
gagne en temps sur le fou et on va jouer
des cas très vite le avec le pion c3 qui
protège toujours cette idée dans la
partie italienne de jouer ces trois des
quatre et voilà donc ici le foot attaqué
alors il ya deux coups de coups
possibles
ouais le coup d'abord x 5 voilà alors
sur sur lequel mais on n'a pas peur de
jouer quand même des 4 on peut jouer
tous les quatre on peut jouir rock aussi
on peut jouer petit rock on se joue et
rock
on peut jouer rock avec les déclas 3 et
4 sont joués des quatre où le roi la d46
les noirs prennent en d4
eh bien on sacrifie tout en faisant
petit rock on n'a pas peur donc là on va
menacer tout simplement de reprendre au
centre avec un très fort centre larissa
faudrait pas laisser faire ça pour les
noirs et si les noirs paix dans ces
trois gars y'a quand même il ya beaucoup
d' attaque avec dame b 3 par exemple
qu'il attaquerait vii qui nous ne serait
de récupérer les pions c3 elle varie d
un fou à 3 qui arrive pour empêcher
éventuellement devra montrer aura montré
il faut montrer parce qu'on est là on a
beaucoup d'idées commun et on prend ces
trois donc ici qui arrive souvent dans
cette seconde mi temps van damme levé
trois grades et les noirs comme ils ont
perdu du temps parce qu'ils ont pris
d'abord le plan b 4 à présent pris le
pion des quatre titres en attendant les
blancs ils ont laissé faire ils ont
ouvert toutes les lignes et maintenant
c'est le temps de récupérer le matériel
voire même deux
de récupérer plus et surtout d'activer
le développement des pièces dans le
métro on développe la dame avec un gain
de temps pourquoi gain de temps puisque
la menace
c'est fou preuve cette protégée par la
dame si les noirs jouent le coup logique
quadrillage 6 ha ils ont oublié quelque
chose là-bas on protège le pion à vii
c'est une grosse erreur j'en ai tiré mon
bonheur c'est bien parce qu'encore une
fois on va trouver dans ce thème
d'élimination du défenseur avec fou
prend un schisme a assez horrible fou
praxis
donc s'il noir reprennent évidemment
leurs théories puisqu'ils ont d'abord
éclaté leur structure de pions allèles
mais en plus ils se prennent au premier
set
on peut dire que la la partie finit la
partie est compromise très compromise a
donc alors eh bien tu as été à 6 ont
trouvé quatre voies la [ __ ] rock puis
on prend ces 3 où elle a pu on prend
cette fois on était pas obligé dans
notre test car fois il faut promet 4 c3
alors là on a fou à 5 qu'on a vu qu'on a
vu et a aussi fou et 7
alors il yal'autre coût possible fouet
cette alors voilà donc là on a montré la
grande idée on revient sur la deuxième
variante ouvriers fawcett voilà voilà
qui est plus calme un peu plus calme et
on va voir qui manquent pas de venin non
plus donc on a eu des fois c'est nous
c'est un peu plus dangereux puisque le
fou n'est plus à la protection du roi
voilà donc là on a plus la pression sur
la diagonale à 5 e 1 donc on ne peut
jouer des quatre immédiatement des
quatre douala est là le problème pour
les noirs vivent ces gens ne
s'inquiètent emprise voilà alors sur un
coup comme 10,6 sur un coup comme des
six soit là pour ça c'est une autre
possibilité
on peut jouer un coup comme d'un mp3
pour attaquer parce qu'il n'y a pas de
pression qui est fait sur notre fou c4
d'ailleurs on va comprendre pourquoi
deux des six
est jouable on lui préfère parfois un
autre coup alors la commune il ya une
pression on sait pas trop quoi en faire
alors les noirs dans ce cas serait
obligé de jouer un coup comme cavalier à
il attaque les deux pièces dame est fou
parce qu'à l'aller blanc récupère le
pion à vii avec elle il faut prendre
cette c63 et fuite
alors il faut aller récupérer le
cavaliere j'en ai mal y en ad rock et on
a quand même un roi qui se balade avec
les noirs bon c'est pas une position qui
est très facile à jouer que de cette
pression sur le plan de sang qui est
toujours présent sur le pion à vii a
disparu on voit très vite aussi que si
les blancs enlève le cavalier f3 après
le petit rock les écoles la f4 ça va
être énorme l'impression au centre avec
une ouverture des lignes sur le roi donc
un jeu très facile à jouer ça fait alors
donc cet os est donc des 90 donc des
quatre cavaliers à cinq ans comprend
mieux maintenant parce qu'on veut pas
laisser le temps aux blancs de faire le
coup d'un b3 qui est très embêtant on a
pris un pion on est à peu près
exactement on a pris un pion donc on est
prêt quand même à rendre pour égaliser à
partie voire même prendre un avantage
positionnelle alors là les blancs ont
rackettés région du mena sans plus
peut-être les pions le bref cette île
ils peuvent à kayes produit 5000 ya
peut-être aussi une petite idée
sympathique
on va montrer quand elle va recaler
prend 1,5 et possible un tel projet sont
tout simplement là on reprend le fou en
c4 qui est le cas elle le foot italien
va bien on n'a pas trop envie avec blanc
donné souffle ou comme un nom soit vous
dommage mais surtout dans ces conditions
la remuée bon alors qu'havas les prends
cavaliers et des cinq des 5 et l'a donc
enlevé cinq d'apprendre des 5 et la
regarder carlier trois à temps regardez
comme c'est beau parce que le terme il
est attaqué il revient le 3 il attaque
la dame et on est aussi protégé le pion
g2 heureusement puisque sinon c'était
quand même embêtant de prendre un à
brancher deux voiles et après on fait un
petit rôle tranquille avec une position
facile à jouer elle partie assez égal ou
chacun de nos grands peuvent faire
valoir ses atouts
voilà donc ça c'est une possibilité
voilà alors sur le coup cavaliers à 5
aussi on a peut-être une autre
possibilité qui suit chacun va te plaire
plus à rien
c'est fou prend f7 voilà fort alors
c'est un peu tendu c'est pas forcément
le meilleur mais alors qu'est ce que
c'est ça fait plaisir quand les morts
font cavalier à 5 sur le bord comme ça
ça fait plaisir de revenir un peu à
l'essence du jeu et le match
ouais voilà c'est fou prend effet trois
preuve sept cavaliers pros la saga va
les prendre c'est qu'avec échec au rang
des comme ce cavalier super au centre
très bel échec ici attention valleroy on
peut très vite perdre pied cette
variante oui alors sur 3,8 par exemple
ça fait peur 3,8 et bien on aura le
traditionnel échec à chuck la marche
cinq échecs
si le roi ici maintenant vian et fuite
ces boîtes on va le montrer tout
simplement ses échecs et mat d'aborder
ce match en dix coups mais aussi ça fait
2e attendit coup qu'on doit quand même
regardé comme la partie italienne est
quand même quelque chose ça peut être
très virulent extrêmement violent et
sinon si si les noirs jouent le coup
regarder le coup j'ai 6 alors c'était
sur la variante avec 3,8 ou alors des
sur le coup j'ai six et bien faire là on
a cavalé projet ici voilà et sur canal
et m6 kid cool on m'a laissé leur l'idée
c'est que j'attaque la dame h5
alors il ya plein de coups mais par
exemple on peut aller prendre le pion
regarder le cavalier à 5 sur wii sauf
que sauf qu'on a déjà donné un peu de
matériel le respect doit pas continuer
dans l'attaqué d'un requin à coups comme
d'un match 4 quand même plus plaisant de
ce cavalier en l'air qu'il faudra jamais
oublier magique à un match classé comme
un gars très peut-être encore meilleur
quand la lame hk avec une position très
intéressante pour un tacle fouet cette
bien sûr qui affaiblirait
considérablement les cases noircies
jamais été perdue pour les neuf ans
après on peut menacer de prendre le sait
depuis toujours et s'inquiète aussi rock
ou 5
voilà un massacre on attaque toujours la
3e suite dont il ya quand même pas mal
de soucis pratique pour les noirs même
si la pression n'est pas encore perdu
mais on met sous pression bon mais
jamais oublier quand même de cavalia
s'inquiète emprise est très souvent à
des variantes ou à la fin on récupère ce
petit cavalier cas l'air de rien sur les
échecs a non seulement on appris du
matériel à droite et puis on
on termine la partie en prenant au
passage ce qui fait quand même
extrêmement mal voilà ça sirois 8 on
peut regarder peut-être sur roy et fuite
alors seront f8
alors là on a un échec directes et nadal
n'ont appris qu'à vannes il ya cinq
échecs roi et fuite
tout simplement on va jouer le coup d'un
f3 en f3 l'échec au roi le coût normal
c'est cammalleri m6 et maintenant on
continue on attaque grâce au cloud âge
du cavaliere 612 g4g tout simplement
avec la simple menace g5 qu'un une pièce
puisque le qualifie son royaume la pièce
à l'écart bénéfices monstrueux qui est
la faiblesse du roi noir
voilà voilà donc ça c est quand même
énorme donc c'est quand même c'est quand
même agréable à jouer si on est hors
d'atteinte il faut pas hésiter
cette variante là et quand même très
bonne aura des belles victoires il y
aura des déconvenues
il rendait partie dure que des parties
mendiants à koné parti marrante étaient
présentes à jouer et c'est bien pour
cent mille quarante ans attaquant ça
c'est clair ouais alors donc
et bien sûr fous ces cinq on a quand
même pas seulement le grand huit evans
on a aussi d'autres coûts on a du coup
ces trois donc qu'il a un coup quand
même un peu plus un peu plus tranquille
un peu plus tranquille
son voeu d'ailleurs parce qu'il ya des
variantes aussi ils sont seuls chaude c3
pour essayer de profiter
c'est l'envié de salaire d'une
opposition des fous ces 5 voilà ça fait
un peu plus tranquille
ces trois donc ça prend la case du
cavalier dont cavaliers m6 c'est le
contre jeu habituel des noirs sur le
plus de 4 c'est normal puisqu'on a pris
la case du naturel du cavalier b1 le cas
il peut pas venir en et 2 donc tout de
suite on attaque le pion aux quatre on
développe une pièce tout à fait logique
alors si on joue des trois on retrouve
pause dans le tuyau copiale géotopia
déjà vu tout à l'heure
voilà qui ressemble à la partie ce panel
rembobinez ou à la regarder et nous on
est des quatre variantes ça peu plus
punchy
c'est un peu la même idée que le gang
dit evans simplement n'a pas joué depuis
quatre ans n'a pas gagné de temps donc
ouais côté n'a pas donné plus en a pas
des pions à l'orne et noir ont quand
même maintenant quelques ficelles pour
se défendre contre des quatre on va les
regarder
c'est objectivement théoriquement pas
très bon pour les blancs mais encore une
fois il ya quand même beaucoup de petits
pièges beaucoup de choses très précises
qu'il faut connaître que tout le monde
ne connaît pas forcément on va regarder
sur france 24 il faut casser le centre
des blues s'est formé suite parce que
sinon on aura donné pour rien et après
on aura du mal à revenir rendement est
là le problème
c'est fou des quatre échecs qui gagnent
un tempo donc évitons noir de d'avoir
à subir des coudes attaques des blancs
oui l'oréal y arriver le rouleau voilà
compresseur 5 décembre qu'il faut vite
faire l'achat et profanes deuxième temps
aux blancs de pousser et la très
étonnamment on va jouer qu'à laisser
trop c'est trop alors on envoie un coup
de fourchette
voilà on jouera pas fou des deux parce
que il raffoux prend plus des cinq qui
égalise au centre mais quand ils ces
trois et bien on se met volontairement
dans le fourrage et alors qu'est ce qui
se passe sur calais prend le cas car les
parents 4 c'est ça qu'il faut connaître
puisque la cavale et prend un carton
récupère en q1 puis tout de suite on
menace évidemment de prendre ces trois
avec un fou qui fera échec au roi et qui
prendra tout est bien tout simplement à
charger comme souvent quand les noirs
vous prendrez pions comme ça de manière
précoce dans l'ouverture on méprise et
on privilégie le développement
on va contre attaquer très vite avec
petits roms tout simplement
donc ça c'est très intéressant il faut
absolument le connaître donc là les
menus les noirs ont deux façons de
prendre ces trois pendant ces trois là
la tentation lecavalier eu quatre
attaques et donc il faut pas faire
partir wade il faut se fait quand même
sauvé la pièce donc soir on se retire
lancé qu'anna ça laisse encore le temps
aux blancs de jouer en tout ou rien soit
si on laisse les dangereux tour où on va
on va avoir des problèmes
exact donc il faut ce qu'il faut trouver
une solution faux pas en c3 avec
françois hop rock le cavalier seul donc
imaginons d'abord français 3 simplement
et dans ce cas là le bon coup pour les
blancs curieusement c'est pas de
reprendre non non mais c'est de jouer le
coup des cinq toiles à des cinq dessins
qui est qui a l'air curieux puisque on
se dit attention effectivement jeu
contre attaque une pièce donc j'ai dit
aux gars toujours des pièces entreprises
donc tout va bien l idée c'est
d'empêcher les noirs de jouer eux mêmes
des cinq ans bien sûr de consolider les
cavaliers au centre voilà et on l'a noté
qu'il ya une variante marrante qu'il
faut
qu'il faut connaître c'est le coup
cavaliers à 5 ou cavaliers e500 près aux
mêmes qui contre attaque sur le fou ces
cas alors vous allez voir vous allez
voir cette variante qui est quand même
superbe un pion prend on prend avec le
fou les noirs évidemment sont venus pour
ça sont menées pour ça ils reprennent le
pouce et quatre élèves d'annuler quatre
alors un cookie énorme pourquoi parce
qu'il attaque à la fois le cas les c4
le 4 est surtout très important le
kiosque s ils n en ont pas d'autre
solution que de faire simplement petit
rock
il faut rendre un peu ils ont fait une
pièce est un pion de plus donc ils ont
la possibilité de rendre une pièce
d'avoir toujours un avantage matériel
d'un pion qui n'est pas forcément
suffisant pour gagner mais qui ont
toutes leur permet de continuer la
partie dans de bonnes conditions
on va quand même voir qu'est ce qui se
passe il garde la pièce s'ils veulent
s'accrocher au matériel alors si les
noirs protège le cavalier centrale ils
vont le garder le cavaliere 4 au 5 sinon
évidemment il y aurait un échec mortelle
de la tour e et bien la regarder la
variante tout simplement tout est
quasiment forcé d'un projet cette
attaque la tour et fuites ou à la menace
évidemment de jouer tôt un suivi d'un à
sac puisque le roi serait à vita au
centre aussi la tour vient la fuite
donc il faut absolument protéger le seul
coup pour les noirs ces jouets 2006 et
là tout simplement
on n'a pas peur des changes et les dames
et non parce que dans une pièce dans les
pièces de moi mais le roi noir est trop
faible et cases noires sont complètement
affaibli par la disparition du projet 7
alors tabler prendre qu'à la dame est là
le cookie tutour eu un effet loin et là
ya pas trop de souci d'aider si les noix
avec le cavalier devant on va le
récupérer
on joue cavalier par le biais du clouage
évidemment cas le 4 on joue tout
simplement car les g5 menace tout
simplement de récupérer les cavaliers et
sur un coup quand même 5 le simple coût
l3 et on a récupéré la pièce voilà avec
avec avantage dynamique
alors s'il est noir tentent de s'en
sortir en
je vous réponds endroit f8 la polio 4 1
pardon au lieu de cabillaud cadre de
jouer le roi et fuite ici
oui tout simplement dont je vous fous g5
voilà bien je me sens parfois swatch et
8,3 via angers mythe
hélas le superbe coup tout au sein
croire dit la menace elle est énorme
puisque c'est de faire toucher 5
échec et mat et ya pas de solution pour
les noirs il faudrait jouer un coup
comme cavalier f4 qui protège la case
gsm est tout simplement on ramène
l'autre tour au centre et aux menaces
tout simplement voilà de faire tout
reprend cavalier est sûre qu'elle va les
prendre cavaliers regarder un match on
va regarder par exemple imaginons que
les noirs jouent en belgique et pas
beaucoup de coups b5 un coup comme vale
b5 on va dire on va montrer simplement
7070 c'est pour s'est pas montré de m on
pourra regarder plein d'autres choses
évidemment tout reprendre la vallier sur
cavaliers prend évidemment c'est matt
voilà donc on se convainquent assez vite
au site ou l'autre coup après tout
rochelle échec le courroie de l'élite
est aussi une erreur à cause de la foule
et 5 qui fait travailler son g 5
alors il n'y a pas de solution bi
dansions joue cavalier ou 4 tout
simplement ton rancart et 1 coupe au
rayon pour preuve il a donc il faut
faire cavalier 8 allée suppression du
défenseur encore une fois il comprendre
défenseur on prend le défenseur s'est
quand même horrible
voilà surtout reprend 8 ont fait fou
prend f6 surtout reprend 1,8
il ya simplement fou prend m6 échec
tours 7 et tous vos seins
la tour est perdu et ont échoué et on va
jouer avec une pièce de plus près
comment puisque les ennuis sont même pas
fini pour les noirs puisqu'il reste
encore attaqué à la découverte la tente
à syrte ou rose 7 et l'autre variante ce
roi prend 1,8 et le seul coup tout
simplement et bien c'est matt après tout
un échec soir au 18
c'est votre droit coup-franc m6 on a tu
sois roi mais fuite
et dans ce cas là que ton je réfléchisse
fois six échecs roi j'ai vite et
maintenant tour c'est avec mata parole
c'est très joli
souvent g5 camatte soit en 1/8 au
prochain concours de toute façon donc
c'est superbe
voilà ça c'est si on laisse le plonger
septembre c'est si on laisse le tourisme
on est pauvre on est prêt à revenir
on a des conseillers effectivement le
faire petit rock
les cinq lots de 5 à 15 des ventes qui
sont très intéressantes petit rosé l'a
simplement il faut prendre on récupère
les cavaliers lecavalier au 4e quart ici
quatre choix la dette totale est le
cavalier ou quatre ça laisse la
possibilité éventuellement au noir de
fer b5 noir peuvent jouer des 5
voilà c'est une partie après
intéressante voilà on a un pion de moins
avec les blancs mais on a quand même
quelques possibilités d'attaqués que le
fouillis palanges et 5 la tour qui
parler en ton à qui peut aller en d1
ensuite des trois ans huit fois
troisième rangée donc la partie continue
et le roc noir est solide mais impose
sans défense pour partie aéré pour les
blancs forcément facile à jouer avec
comme seuls moyens quand même donc c'est
suite quand même peu tendu si on aime
bien défendre avec les noirs à long
terme on peut gagner la partie
mais par contre on est bien attaquer
c'est la partie qu'il faut jouer sans
hésiter on a donné un pion pour une
partie facile
voilà donc pour résumer sur cette
variante italienne eh bien il ya deux
coups la cavalière 6 il ya un fou ces
cinq voix la cavaille aussi c'est fou
ces cinq donc on l'a vu après fou c4 on
a vu les deux grandes variantes avec les
développements possibles avis est très
riche évidemment peut pas faire le tour
de la fille laurie là dessus et que
c'est puis les blancs si vous savez que
les blancs vous avez choix quel qu'un
jour vous n'êtes pas en forme ça de
jouer le joko piano qui peut être un bon
complément éventuellement de
connaissances sur la partie espagnole
vous pouvez alterner avec une italienne
un couvent une espagnole et vous avez à
peu près les mêmes thèmes de
construction centrales qui sont très
intéressants cette partie italienne
voilà donc merci jean matip ont déçu
alors c'est une leçon très dense qu'on a
vue là c'est parce qu'on a vu quasiment
toutes les grandes lignes théorique
vouloir passer seulement voila voila
repasser plein façon c'est l'info la
connaître par coeur et ça vous fera
gagner beaucoup moins en partie les
considérations positionnelle puis devant
tactique qui sont très pointus et voilà
vous pouvez la mettre ça chez vous sur
votre échiquier puis réfléchir tout seul
il ya beaucoup de choses à se prouver
par vous-même aussi beaucoup de beaucoup
de points gagnés avec ça voilà merci
pour avoir suivi cette leçon spéciale
italienne à bientôt au roi